at a hotel in geneva the u.s secretary
of state and russian foreign minister
arrived for crucial talks aimed at
diffusing tensions over ukraine anthony
blinken and sergey lavrov set the tone
early both said a breakthrough was
unlikely
we don't expect to resolve our
differences
here today
but i do hope and expect that we can
test whether the
diplomacy or dialogue
remains
we are not expecting a breakthrough at
this meeting either we are expecting
answers to our proposals
after the meeting lavrov said moscow
wanted a written response from the u.s
to its demands including a guarantee
that nato will not grant membership to
ukraine something blinken has repeatedly
called a non-starter but he said the u.s
would respond to russia if moscow
addressed its concerns and respected
ukrainian sovereignty
we've been clear
if any russian military forces move
across ukraine's border
that's a renewed invasion
it will be met with swift severe and a
united response from the united states
and our partners and allies
u.s intelligence says russia has already
amassed at least a hundred thousand
troops on its western border and is
moving weapons into allied belarus north
of ukraine
the u.s and russian positions are
clearly far apart blinken and lavrov
making very little real progress but the
two men did agree to continue to pursue
diplomacy as a way of de-escalating a
crisis which could lead to war
it was on the shores of lake geneva that
talks between the u.s and russia led to
the end of the cold war decades on her
old rivalries have resurfaced both sides
accuse each other of aggression and
relations have dangerously deteriorated
the outlook for the coming weeks is
turbulent
natasha butler al jazeera geneva